Hollow Knight is a remarkable
achievement in both story and game
design its narrative is incredibly
interesting as it forces you to uncover
the secrets of the world yourself while
also having a large cast of characters
that for the most part are delightful to
talk to but it also has a couple issues
regarding its method of Storytelling as
some of its story is strangely not in
the game but in other material and it
has one DLC that almost ruins the
original story that the game builds up
we'll talk about all that in due time
though as this video will not only
explain the story of hollow Knight so
you know what's going on in the
hollownest but I'll also be critiquing
it along the way I have a lot of things
to say about this game so let's not
waste any time and let's get started
the game starts with a cutscene of a
being locked inside some device an
orange glow appears and seems to crack
something before showing another scene
but of our protagonist the night sadly
we aren't given any information
following this as we start playing
immediately after the path we start on
will take us to a town called dirtmouth
with his only resident being the Elder
bug who greets us upon our arrival from
his dialogue it seems like we aren't the
first people to arrive here and we
certainly won't be the last he also
assumes we only came here to visit the
Eternal kingdom known as hollownest from
there he tells us that the entrance to
this underground kingdom is down the
well right outside the town afterwards
uh that's it that's all he says Hollow
Knight makes it pretty clear right away
that its story is pretty vague we
technically don't have a quest or
objective or even a motivation to be
here hell we just found out what the
Kingdom is called this might seem like a
bit much as it's quite bold for the devs
to just throw the player into the world
and then refuse to give them a reason as
to why they're even here but while the
game refuses to elaborate on anything
I'll say that at the very least there is
a reason for the night being here
specifically as their birth and Destiny
are tied to this place but that's
something we'll have to talk about later
fortunately while the story is too shy
to introduce itself just yet the
gameplay is more than happy to make your
acquaintance Helena is a metroidvania
and is one of the few games on this
channel I would recommend for purely the
gameplay alone the story was really the
cherry on top of all this as the
gameplay is fantastic there is a lot to
go over regarding the gameplay but
basically you'll be exploring all the
hallways dead ends and crevices of the
hollowness you can uncover its Secrets
this fits quite well regarding the story
as presumably both the Knight and the
player have no idea what they're doing
here and by exploring this Kingdom they
might just find the answer along the way
I'll also get Geo the game's currency is
as well as find some charms you could
slot under not just to increase your
power these range of things like extra
damage and more Health to more
situational things like having Geo come
to you instead of just scattering all
over the floor or shrinking your size
when healing making it harder to hit you
there are also a ton of items hidden
throughout the map like Keys rancid eggs
and upgrade materials some players even
have the ability to Grant you spells or
passive abilities like dashing or double
jumping Plus in true metroidvania style
whole areas Are Walled off until you get
these items or even smaller sections of
already accessible areas meaning you'll
have to be backtracking constantly
Hollow Knight will also try to challenge
the player in numerous ways either
giving them hard bosses or by adding
platforming puzzles to it as well but
even if this proves too easy for you
upon completing the game you're given
access to a steel Soul mode which is
basically a permadeath challenge where
you have to beat the whole game without
failing as dying deletes your save like
I said there was a lot to hollow
Knight's gameplay but it is wonderful as
not only do I think the charm system is
what really brings us all together but
there is a surprising amount of depth to
the gameplay as well Hollow Knight's
gameplay really was great to mess around
with and experience which is quite
important for a game like this given
that the next five to eight hours or so
with back-to-back combat encounters
without much development in the story so
it really needs to hook you in
immediately and fortunately for the game
it did right away
earlier I talked about how the night's
level design and how it's all connected
requiring the player to backtrack
throughout the levels this makes talking
about the story difficult is there
really isn't a proper place to start for
example a game that we talked about
before that is also getting a sequel in
a couple weeks that I plan to talk about
Blasphemous had a well-paced and
structured story you were told by the
first person you meet to find the three
humiliations originally you were locked
off to the first half of the map but
once you found those three humiliations
the second half would be open to you
until you reach the end Hollow Knight
doesn't really do this as a large
portion of the game is just spent
finding the actual objective and then
doing it and then once that's complete
you're on to the final boss it's a bit
of an odd way to structure a story and
definitely makes my job harder as I
prefer to organize things a bit but
fortunately a part of hollow Knight's
story that isn't explained is the
exploration itself walking around
hollownest meeting with NPCs exploring
new locations all of it is the story as
exploring the kingdom will eventually
lead you to some interesting locations
that further develop the actual story
and the ending Hollow Knight is both a
story about hollownest and the knight's
journey and uncovering what happened in
Hollow and I really like this take on
the storytelling as being thrust into an
unknown land without explanation forces
the player to seek out answers to their
own questions the game never says in the
beginning that hollowness fell to ruin
and is a shell of its former self you
ask the questions then you find the
answer why is hollowness filled with
different kinds of bugs why are some
locations built differently than others
where did it all go wrong just like the
gameplay Hollow knight story allows the
player enough for him to express
themselves most of the time you get in
what you put out if you want to learn
about hollowness then you'll find the
answers to your questions but if you
don't want to engage with its world then
you won't get anything out of it this
not only satisfies the kinds of players
who enjoy games for the gameplay as they
don't need to be forced into a story
they don't care about but dare I say it
it kind of brought me back to Dark Souls
1. exploring Dark Souls 1 for the first
time and simultaneously figuring out my
own purpose in this world while also
figuring out how it all came to be is
one of the best experiences I've ever
had playing a game before and Hollow
Knight sort of encapsulates that feeling
I honestly never thought I would say
that before but it's true learning about
hollownest in his residence while trying
to understand the knight's role in all
this was exactly how I felt when I
stepped into lordram for the first time
and I'm genuinely impressed sadly as I
said before though there really isn't a
definitive objective in this game as the
objective for now is to find that
objective thankfully the game is willing
to feed us a breadcrumb trail of mystery
until we get there as while exploring
the hollowness you'll come across quite
a few peculiar things the first is this
black egg Temple located in the
Forgotten Crossroads its design is
similar to the one in the intro so
clearly this place might house that
orange glow we saw earlier sadly we
can't open it though as there seems to
be a lock on it so we'll have to come
back once we find the keys during our
travels we'll also made a few NPCs like
Elder bug zote Hornet and the hunter
while they're all great in their own way
it's their designs I'm more interested
in hollownest is filled with all kinds
of insects and bugs from mantises to
jellyfish to bees yet among them are a
few bugs that look like our Knight at
the time it could be assumed that the
Knight is one of a kind or is from
somewhere else but there are quite a few
bugs that have similar head shapes Zodi
is the best example of this as he looks
identical to the Knight minus the face
Hornet is less so but she like the
Knight has a white mask of sorts and
this kind of design is only seen on a
few creatures this gives the player the
impression that the Knight might have
originated here although at the moment
it's just speculation the hunter on the
other hand doesn't look anything like
the aforementioned NPCs but he serves
another purpose as upon meeting him
he'll give the player a journal this
journal is basically a bestiary of all
the enemies we come across on our
journey but after killing a certain
amount new tech starts to appear which
may give some answers as to what these
bugs are admittedly it's not all helpful
as most of it seems to be written from
the perspective of the hunter himself
who always takes the chance to insult
the beings we kill but sometimes his
words can be useful talking to NPCs
reading the Hunter's journal and
discovering these Stone writings I call
Lore tablets are the core pillars that
make up Hollow Knight source of
information and thanks to these we're
able to learn quite a bit about the bugs
here
the first group of individuals you'll
come across are the husks these are your
standard enemy but they do come in a
variety of shapes and sizes this group
is seen in places like the Forgotten
Crossroads the crystal peak in the city
of Tears judging for the locations we
find them in we could assume that the
city of Tears is a place for the wealthy
and the Forgotten crossovers is more for
the poor and middle class while the
crystal Peak sort of acts as a source of
power for the kingdom the crystals
located here have a faint amount of soul
in them which are a part of the life
essence of all bugs in hollowness so
they're quite valuable to the kingdom as
for the other settlements though many of
the husks within the city of tears are
extremely wealthy due to them being
ordained in beautiful clothing and
jewelry along with the fact that they
drop more Geo when killed some of the
residents seem to even be trying to
capitalize on the downfall of the
Kingdom by making a quick buck as this
sweet grandma named miliba will hold
their Geo for you in her bank but after
enough time we'll run off with it that
is until you confront her and get it
back the city of Tears also got its name
thanks to it being built Under the Blue
Lake which is where the rain comes from
funny enough I never found it odd or
even bothered to wonder why it rained
here even though the entire kingdom is
underground although given that this
place has jellyfish fungal mushrooms
acid water and a literal pool of
Darkness I guess the thought never
crossed my mind regardless not much else
is mentioned about these places but
there are a few signs pointing towards
the city of Tears like it's some kind of
pilgrimage and seeing as this place is
considered the heart of the Kingdom it's
no wonder many people revered it and
thus took great strides to get here but
that pilgrimage may have been an
unattended death trap for many as
located at the top of the city is the
soul sanctum and various lore
descriptions point to the scholars here
using the citizens of the city in
various experiments they seemed to have
been a normal group of Scholars looking
to harness the powers of the mind but
after an infection swept through the
kingdom they attempted to stop it using
the power of Soul Souls I said is
considered the life force of all life
and hollowness so in order to gain more
Soul the scholars took to the streets
and kidnapped or outright killed many of
its residents and then dumped the bodies
at the bottom of the sanctum to make
matters worse not only did many of their
experiments fail as these blob-like
beings are the results of their failed
tests but it didn't seem to produce any
worthwhile results anyway as no
information can be gleaned from their
testing and none of the scholars are
alive to tell us what they uncover hurt
it's a pretty gruesome story to say the
least but it's one of the stronger ones
than Hollow Knight as it provides a
wealth of knowledge on the city and its
inhabitants in addition to the added
entry that comes from a place such as
this
fortunately this Intrigue also carries
over into the next area called The Green
Path which is run by the moskin tribe
what might surprise you about them
though is that the Moss can aren't too
interested in the Kingdom's ruler or
their people colonists was created by
The Pale King who rules over its land
along with his Queen the white lady but
not all the groups live in harmony the
Moss can don't hate The Pale King and
his people but they don't really care
for them either they seem to just merely
tolerate them as they allowed people to
come into their land and even build
roads on them but warn them not to stray
too far off the paths they built to many
of the bugs in hollowness The Pale King
can be seen as a God in fact this is
true in more ways than one as he's with
the game calls a higher being The Pale
King came here from a distant land and
decided to create a kingdom for his
eventual subjects to live in according
to various lore tablets he was also able
to Grant the bug sapiens allowing them
to think instead of act on Instinct not
all the bugs have this as some of the
enemies in this game are sort of like
animals in the real world but most the
bugs were granted this power by The Pale
King that's why the creatures of this
Kingdom can even talk in the first place
this power also only seems to extend too
hollowness as a few more or lore tablets
in the outskirts of the Kingdom warn us
that leaving its grounds will basically
make us lose the powers we were given
that's kind of why I like the intro of
the game despite it not giving us a
reason to do anything because the Knight
likely lost their memory of hollownest
or at least doesn't have any cognitive
thought until approaching its Gates we
don't know what hollownest is or what
we're doing here because the Knight
doesn't even know either the both of us
are just kind of going with the flow at
this point and while I was skeptical at
first I started to appreciate why the
dev team was so secretive at the start
back to the moskin they knew of the pale
King's existence but unlike other bugs
didn't worship him as they worshiped
something called un un is another higher
being in the game one of which the
mosque Kim believes created them and
their land we do actually get to meet
this on though but the conversation is
well quite hard to call a conversation
great talk on thanks your people are
definitely not in desperate need of your
arrival or anything but uh thanks for
the charm yeah un isn't very talkative
and also seems to not be responding to
her people's call as a lot of the
dialogue implies that she's not
answering them this actually seems to
have led some of the mosque in to turn
their backs on on and worship something
they call the light this might not mean
much now but it's kind of interesting to
see how early the foreshadowing started
here near the Green Path is our next
location the Queen's Garden which not
only houses the mosque in but also the
Mantis tribe they're a bit hard to pin
down at first as they also have their
own village in the fungal waste and
that's because the group was split due
to an altercation the mantises we find
in the Queen's Garden are called the
traitors this is because of that
infection I briefly mentioned earlier it
somehow managed to find its way into the
Mantis Village but fortunately for them
they're able to resist its effects
unlike the rest of the Kingdom
unfortunately though not everyone was
too keen on just letting this thing
exist without at least looking into it
and after some time members of the tribe
began to embrace this infection this led
to a dispute between some of the higher
up members of the tribe which resulted
in those that embrace the infection
being forced to leave the village the
one thing they both agree on though is
that they don't care about The Pale King
either whereas the mosque King tolerated
their new neighbors the mantises refused
to join up with them at most they
entered a truce with The Pale King that
said that they wouldn't be involved in
their way of life but would keep the
Deep nest and its monsters away from the
rest of the Kingdom the reason why is
the Deep Nest houses quite a few other
species that also aren't too keen on
visitors either the Deep Nest is home to
the current species the spider tribe and
a long forgotten group called The
Weavers we don't know too much about the
waivers as they left the Deep Nest some
time ago thanks to that aforementioned
infection sweeped in the land this place
also seems to be quite primitive even
though one of its inhabitants claimed
that this place is the home to the most
intelligent species in the world
although that's likely just bias on her
end this seems to be a bit of a
recurring theme here but another group
of individuals that also rejected the
pale King's rule are the bees of the
hive they went as far as wand themselves
off on the rest of the kingdom is the
only way to access their hive is through
secret breakable walls thanks to their
seclusion though we aren't able to learn
much about them but we do know that
their Queen grew so large she was unable
to leave the hive ultimately ending in
her death which is why the hive is in
such disarray When we arrive this pretty
much covers the main tribes and
locations of hollownest but we haven't
even scratched the surface yet there are
both whole tribes and important members
of the previous tribes that I
intentionally left out thanks to them
being more important to the main story
entire areas I left out for the same
reasons and some other things just due
to the lack of importance like the
flukes and the mushrooms but even
without them we've already learned so
much about this place every inch of this
kingdom is filled with storage for the
player to uncover and it's what makes
Hollow Knight such a fascinating game to
play is they're essentially collecting
puzzle pieces that will eventually
create the puzzle that is hollow Knight
plus given the genre of this game most
of this info will be fed you throughout
the playthrough so you might not be able
to learn everything about a single
location or tribe in one visit it's this
constant cycle of finding information
and being interested enough in what you
found to go look for more and it's these
moments where Hollow Knight is at its
best like I said and most of the time
what you put in is what you get out and
Hollow Knight's biggest strength is
giving the player a wealth of
information to find should they choose
to I say most of the time though is not
everything is in answered and that's one
of the sore spots of this game I don't
have an issue with the game not telling
you things it's where that information
comes from alongside Hollow Knight were
a few pieces of external media that
being an official manual a prequel comic
and something called The Wanderers
Journal quite a bit of this game's story
can be found here and only here a great
example would be the hive everything I
mentioned about the hive was not found
in the game at the time I'd gone through
the whole Hive and came out with nothing
which was bizarre given every other
location was the complete opposite so I
looked it up just to make sure I didn't
miss a secret room or anything only to
discover that I was destined not to find
this information had I not looked it up
the only dialogue of note and the hive
comes from the ghost of Queen Vespa
herself all she says is a thank you for
setting her night free from the torment
of the infection and that the hive plays
no part in hollowness perpetuation
however we know that there is more to
this but that's because it comes from
the other sources the official manual
says that the hive was a tribe that
walled themselves off from The Pale King
it also states that Queen Vespa grew too
big and died because of it to make
things even worse we learned that the
reason that the hive is in such disarray
is because the infection was able to
overpower the Beast thanks to their
Queen dying but we only know of that
information thanks to an ask me anything
Reddit thread now I've played games
before that answer questions in things
like books and movies but a Reddit
thread is definitely a new one for me
none of this information is in the game
as the only dialogue in the area comes
from the queen and the Hunter's Journal
also provides no further Insight either
even the one thing that could have been
interesting which is the fact that the
bees also have bee hives with husks in
them is used as a way to make a joke as
the Hunter's Journal says quote did the
husk squeeze in the hive or did the bees
build their nests around them either way
they seem pretty happy together this is
a group that walled off its borders from
everyone else yet has husks from
hollownest in their domain and it's not
brought up at all look I can see how
some people might find this interesting
as in a way it's sort of like its own
scavenger hunt to find all this external
info but you have to understand that
that last piece of info would not have
been known had it not been for the
person who asked that question and for
one of the devs who responded had the
team simply decided that they were in
the to answer more questions or even do
the thread at all this would not have
been known and realistically is the hive
important to the story of hollow Knights
not really which is an issue in and of
itself as is probably the least
developed and interesting location in
the whole game but I feel like adding in
basic information should have been a top
priority here I have no issue with the
game refusing to answer certain things
about its world but not including
something as basic as why the place
exists or how it came to be the way that
it is in the present day is bizarre as
almost ever the location doesn't do this
and gladly provides you with enough
information to either tell you what
happened or at least give you hints as
to what could have happened
regardless that's probably my biggest
issue regarding Hollow Knight's
storytelling as yes while Hal and I can
be a hard game to piece together it's
quite annoying to actually put in the
work to learn about this game without
knowing that you won't ever find certain
info thanks to the tune deciding that a
book or Journal was a better place for
it to be even though most players likely
didn't buy this or even know that it
exists in the first place
within the many locations of hollowness
there also dozens of residents at the
night can talk and interact with the
NPCs of hollow Knight are another core
part of the exploration as you're able
to learn quite a few things about the
Kingdom from them while also
occasionally embarking on quests with
them as well that said they are an 80 20
split ranging from Fantastic to
borderline pointless a great example of
the latter would be emilisha you'll find
her lounging around the upper parts of
the city of tears and from talking with
her we could see that she's laughing at
the current state of the city as the
same people who cast her out of
hollowness high society are now the
Mindless Huss wandering around aimlessly
outside of this one detail though she's
completely useless returning to her
doesn't add anything and even when you
come back with specific items like the
Delica flower or the king's brand she
only makes a quick remark and that's all
she also doesn't provide anything for
the purposes of gameplay except the fact
that her room can be used as a quick
shortcut to the Royal waterways but I
never found much use for it another
example would also be Willow This Tall
creature relaxing in the Queen's station
all of her dialogue centers around her
eating the food here and even now she
wants to eat the night but knows that
they won't let her Willow is arguably
worse though as unlike a militia you
can't come back to get new dialogue you
can listen to everything she says the
moment you meet her as having specific
Quest items won't give you more dialogue
furthermore she also doesn't provide any
services that will assist with gameplay
unless you count the one sellable item
hidden above her on the complete other
side of the Spectrum in terms of quality
though we have someone like zote you
find him in the Forgotten Crossroads
being eaten by avengefly King once you
kill the Beast instead of zote thanking
you he scold you for taking his kill Zod
immediately comes off as an and
this continues throughout his entire
questline he'll end up getting caught
again in the Deep nest and not only does
he not remember you but he also talks
about his recent exploits such as
killing a flying Beast meaning in
addition to getting mad at us for saving
him he also takes credit for the kill
this all comes to a head at the Coliseum
of fools a fighting arena within
hollownest for the final boss of the
first trial is zote and not only is he
incredibly easy he can't even damage you
not even contact damage something the
literal weakest enemies in the game can
do doesn't even affect you it's a
therapeutic experience as you could
finally take your anger out on him for
the number of times he's berated you but
somehow zote schemes know no bounds as
if you defeat him in the Coliseum but
also save another bug called Bretta and
the fungal waste she falls in love with
zote instead of you as he Regals her
about his recent killings by holding the
helmet of an enemy we defeated Bretta is
head over heels for the night that she
sees them as her knight in shining armor
and even writes a few poems about us but
now all her attention is on zote if
you're really annoyed with him at this
point you can fight his dream version
called gray prinzot which after enough
time will cause her to lose interest in
him but it's an amazing questline
regardless
now obviously the reason for this Stark
difference in quality is the fact that
zote has an actual questline that the
player can complete unlike a militia or
Willow but that doesn't automatically
make him a fantastic NPC as some
characters have quest lines but are also
not interesting to me while others have
none but were some of my favorite bugs
to talk to tiso is a great example of an
NPC with a quest line that still managed
to lose my interest as they're basically
a poor man zote tiso arrives in
Dartmouth at one point and talks about
wanting to fight people they'll also
appear near the Blue Lake and on a bench
near a stag station and constantly
remark how pitiful or boring these
things are eventually tiso will find
their way to the Coliseum but unlike Zod
you can actually find their corpse
falling from the Coliseum like the
dozens of others before him we never
actually get to see tiso fight and the
one time we actually could fight him
which is in a future DLC they pull a
fake out and have him be crushed by the
actual boss of the pantheon admittedly
that last part did get a chuckle out of
me batizo's Quest is confusing as he has
two reasons for existing at least that I
can think of but neither of them LED
anywhere interesting to me if tiso was
meant to be a warrior that is in over
his head and despite talking up a big
game is actually really weak then they
really are a discount zote but if in a
roundabout way he's used to convey how
dangerous the Coliseum is as someone has
experienced as tiso couldn't even
survive then that doesn't work either as
we don't know how strong tiso actually
is we never see him fight throughout the
entirety of the game or even see the
remnants of a fight they just talk about
fighting and then die at least with zote
we could see how incompetent he was from
the two times we see him which makes his
fight even better as while the player
likely knew he was weak they probably
didn't know he was that bad on the other
side of the coin though there are quite
a few NPCs I grew to like due to their
personality or the relation to other
characters yet didn't have any quest
lines at all two of which I want to
specifically highlight are cornifer and
Mila they are probably the two most
likable NPCs in the whole game both of
them don't have a questline but talking
with them always felt nice Myla is just
a bug who mines away in the crystal Peak
right away she comes off as extremely
likable as she's pleased to make your
acquaintance and is very happy to see
you again if if you return to her most
of her dialogue is also lines from a
song she slowly starts to remember over
the course of the game until the
infection returns and overcomes her
forcing the player to flee or to put her
down I didn't visit Mila matcha my
playthrough but anytime I came to the
crystal Peak I always made sure to say
hi even if it was repeated dialogue As I
Grew to like her delightful personality
similar to Mila kronifer is also
extremely friendly right from the start
as you and him both have a common
obsession with exploring unknown lands
you don't meet corner for much outside
of these occasional talks with him but
it was nice to know that someone else
was going through these areas with me
and meeting with him to talk about our
adventures was always nice to hear
eventually once you buy all of his Maps
cornerful will return to his wife is
sell this house and sleep for the
remainder of the game she's also a good
example of a character that's likable
due to their relationship with another
NPC I liked cornivers so clearly I'm
going to like his wife and while she
didn't add much to the conversation you
do learn that she used to be a fighter
until she settled down with him a few
years ago she also plans on asking if
she can come with him on their next
adventure as his tales about the
hollowness got her interested to see
what her husband's been up to once again
it doesn't take a whole lot for me to
enjoy the company of a character and
Myla and cornifer are great examples of
that as their personalities were
infectious enough for me to care about
them from the moment I met them as I
mentioned earlier Hollow Knight's NPCs
can be a mixed bag but overall there is
a lovely cast of characters that I'll
attempt to add something to the game
even if it's small even though some of
them weren't too interesting by the end
I was at least curious to see how they
would develop once I met them plus all
this ties back into the game's core idea
of exploration as you'll never know what
you'll find around Each corner many of
the NPCs carry with them this sense of
mystery as you wonder where things will
go next and this even extends to the
ones we didn't mention like how the nail
Masters are all brothers who trained
under nail Sage Sly but they all
separated as two of the brothers have a
strenuous relationship possibly due to
something in their past or the nail
Smith the one who upgrades our gear who
ends up asking us to kill him as they've
completed their life's work but will end
up living with one of the nail Masters
if we choose to spare them then there's
cloth who's on the search for stronger
foes but ends up dying at the end of
their questline which is sad Until you
realize that it seems like they wanted
this to happen as they were trying to
meet with someone called NOLA who seemed
to have died long ago even as someone as
irrelevant as the grub father carries a
mystery with them as all his children
have been presumably taken by this being
known as The Collector who who is also
another topic of mystery as they seem to
be related to The King's mold guards
that guard the pale King's Chambers as a
mold of its body is found in one of the
rooms but the collector seems to want to
save them either because they have a
fascination with these creatures or
maybe they don't want them to die
because if you rescue all the grubs we
find out that the grub father ate them
all but even that is mysterious because
the grope fly elegy charm could be what
the grubfother is going to turn into or
maybe the grubfather is like the Gru's
mother boss fight and is being used as
some kind of cocoon in order to evolve
his children not everything will lead to
an answer but not only is this part of
the game's charm as most of the time
there's enough info given to at least
speculate on what could happen but the
tribe's tablets enemies NPCs and
locations are all things you can find
and no matter how small they are each
will create some kind of new and
exciting experience for you to enjoy
while hollownest has its fair share of
history for us to learn much of which
we've already talked about something
that's been quite consistent among most
of its history has been the mentioning
of a widespread infection this infection
is why hollowness is in the shape that
it's in something you may have thought
about while exploring the kingdom is why
everyone's trying to kill us are they
simply protecting their people are we
some kind of killer to these people are
their minds overcome with an infection
that regressed them back to their old
thoughtless States before the pale
King's arrival did I just spoil the
entire plot well that's what we're going
to find out as well the game never tells
you to search for clues about the
infection there are enough things that
showcase or talk about it that it's hard
to ignore
the real beginning of the story starts
with our meeting with Hornet we first
see her in the Green Path as she moves
out of our view right when we get close
when we finally catch up to her we see
that she's killed another bug that looks
similar to us this event forces us to
question what's going on here and while
not technically true my first thought
was that Hornet was tracking us down and
killing our people and this was
basically all but confirmed the moment
she started to fight me after our talk I
started to question Hornet and her role
in the story though as the next time we
meet her is at the city of Tears in the
town statue as we approach Hornet will
come to greet us but unlike last time
she's just here to talk which is
followed up by her saying that if we
want to know the truth we should keep
searching and if by then we still want
to continue the plan then we must seek
out the grave in Ash and find the mark
buried there it's about as vague as you
could possibly get but at least we know
we're on the right track much of her
dialogue about the past of this Kingdom
though has to do with the Statue right
next to us it's a memorial for the John
Hollow Knight who is apparently located
in a Black Vault above the city and who
made the ultimate sacrifice to save
hollownest next to them are three beings
who look eerily similar to the three
beings we see after we defeat Hornet
their masks also look like the masks on
the black egg we saw earlier which
confirms that not only are these B
beings the key but that the hollow
Knight is inside that Temple at the
moment the player has no idea what any
of this means but to spoil it ahead of
time the pill king and the white lady
use the hollow Knight as a vessel to
seal the infection originally The Pale
King likely figured his five great
Knights could handle it but it seems
like they too have succumbed to its
effects the five grid Knights of
hollowness were named hegemold Draya
zamir isma and ogram dry and ismar both
dead due to various circumstances dry
because she was defending the white lady
from the Mantis traders who sought to
kill her and isma is attached to the
wall via these plants but it's unclear
if that's what killed her or not zamir
and ogram are the only two that are
confirmed to be alive as they're the
gray mourner and dung Defender
respectively zamir seems to be extremely
depressed over the loss of her lover who
is oddly enough the traitor Lord's child
and ogram seems to have gone manic due
to his fascination with dung although
it's possible he was always like this
hegemold is the oddest of the five
though as his status is up in the air as
his armor was taken by a maggot when he
was sleeping who we know is the false
Knight it's unclear whether this being
killed hegemold while he slept or just
took his arm armor but at the moment
hegemold is possibly defenseless and
wandering around the hollowness looking
for his armor either way not even the
great Knights of hollowness could defeat
this being as ogram himself says that
it's hard to kill something that has no
form so The Pale King had to take
drastic measures by using the hollow
Knight as a vessel he would then take
this being inside the black egg Temple
and then use these three people called
dreamers as lox in order to prevent it
from opening our main objective is
eventually going to be to find these
dreamers and then defeat them so we can
get inside the egg but we don't even
know where to start yet thankfully there
is a shrine that can give us the
locations unfortunately we also get sent
into the dream Room by The Dreamers
themselves just like its name implies
this is a realm conjured up by dreams
this is due to the being who's helping
us Escape called Seer they're the last
member of the moth tribe who were able
to manipulate dreams they like some of
the other tribes used to worship their
own higher being called the radiance as
according to them they were born of its
light over time though the tribe had
forsaken its God in favor of The Pale
King once he arrived the king then gave
them the job of watching over the dead
due to their Affinity with the dream
realm that's how Seer was able to help
us shape and why they're located here in
the resting grounds which is a place
within hollowness where the dead would
be buried and loved ones would come to
perform rituals and say prayers Seer
feels guilty for this though and wants
to atone for their ancestors mistakes of
not worshiping their true creator by
helping us out that may sound a bit odd
given that we have no connection to the
radiance but you'd be surprised how
connected the Knight and their God are
you might even say it's the only reason
the Knight exists I'll get to all that
later as for now sear gives us a dream
now which allows us to appear into the
minds of those in hollowness and read
their thoughts this serves as both a
story and gameplay device as gameplay
wise it'll allow us to not only
challenge new bosses called The Warrior
dreams but also let us fight stronger
versions of older bosses like the false
Knight who is now called the failed
Champion it's not every boss in the game
but it gives the player more content to
mess around with as for the warrior
dreams these are all important people
within hollowness history and while none
of them really add anything to the main
story they're a nice way of adding World
building to the game for example Elder
who was a monk who came to the Mantis
Village in order to cure those afflicted
by the infection but end up being killed
by the Mantis tribe is he had
unknowingly been affected himself
there's also no wise who ripped her in
her people's eyes out in an attempt to
stop the visions and Nightmares they
were having thanks to the infection now
not every Warrior dream is as compelling
as these as Galion for example just
wanted to prove his Worth to The Pale
King as he was one of the strongest
knights around so he ventured into the
deepness looking for battle only to die
shortly after arriving but still there
were not only fun fights but they added
to the World building and exploration of
hollow Knight by giving the player even
more things to uncover in this vast
Kingdom
circling back to the dream nail though
while those aforementioned details are
more centered around the gameplay
story-wise it allows us to peer into the
minds of NPCs and bosses adding yet
another item to our arsenal of Story
tools as next to lore tablets MBC
dialogue in the Hunter's Journal now
sits the dream now I will say while this
game can be a bit overwhelming at times
when it comes to how much content there
is to uncover and how much reading is
you need to actually lay out a proper
timeline of events it's only worth the
effort but the variety of tools we have
allows for more creative options instead
of having an MPC info dump information
to us the team can instead turn it into
dream nail dialogue this gives us more
pieces to the puzzle in addition to
making us question why they didn't say
that to us such as the mask maker who
wonders if the Knight knows about the
face that hides beneath theirs why
didn't he say that to the Knight is the
mask maker hiding something or does he
want them to find out for themselves
it's honestly a really genius mechanic
thanks to adding even more depth to the
story than there immediately already was
returning back to the story thanks this
year giving us the dream now we can now
use this on the other beings we call the
dreamers in order to defeat them at the
moment we don't know that the dream node
will be used in this way as the game
never tells us but it's something you'll
find out very quickly as none of the
dreamers are actually alive the three
dreamers are named manamana Lorien and
Hera and each one is located in a
different part of hollownest and has
their own stories for us to uncover
however due to the freedom and
flexibility of power Knight's gameplay
you could challenge them in any order
you wish so we'll just go in the order
that I took them on which means manaman
is up first
within the fog Canyon is a large
building called the teachers archives
just outside its store is a being named
Coral this is an MPC you'll likely meet
throughout your journey who like the
night has come here for an unknown
reason most of his talks are about the
areas in which you find him in like
questioning where the rain comes from in
the city of Tears or mentioning how it's
said to see that the miners of the
crystal Peak are still mining away at
the walls despite being overcome by the
infection
Within These talks though mainly thanks
to the dream now we can tell that Coral
has been tasked with something and has
come here for a reason and after enough
exploring his quest has led him here he
claims that this building feels familiar
to him in fact quite a few things about
the hollowness feel familiar to him as
he seems to remember the nail Smith but
can't figure out why and then goes on to
talk about the crystals within the peak
which is Then followed up by him saying
such strange ancient facts I wonder
where my knowledge comes from the reason
he's having these thoughts is because
he's lived here before furthermore he
knows manaman all too well as he's her
Apprentice monoman seems to be a teacher
and researcher within hollownest as her
quarters are filled with test tubes and
lab notes it's unclear why her lab is
here of all places but it is quite a
ways away from the other tribes and it's
also possible that the jellyfish here
are what she was studying at the time
before becoming a dreamer she was also
likely chosen for this role due to her
immense knowledge of the hollownest
seeing as she's quite the intellect it's
no wonder she had put in place numerous
fail-saves to make sure her plan
succeeded as defending her is umu a
giant sentient jellyfish whose whole
purpose is to defend the archive with
her other protector being quarrel
himself as the mask he wears as a hat
has the same design as hers she seems to
have called the coral back to the
hollowness in order to set her free as
Coral not only lets us defeat her but
also helps us fight umu so clearly we
have the same goal this also means that
setting them free seems to be the right
plan at least at the moment the dreamers
were obviously tasked with Sue in the
hollow Knight but killing them would in
theory set it free but manaman seems to
think this is the right idea and her
dream nail dialogue corroborates this as
she wants the seals of the temple to
break so we end up following along and
going into the dream realm to defeat
monomon thankfully it's not another boss
fight as all that's required of us is to
hit her and then absorb her Essence into
US returning to the real world sees
Coral sitting by the tank that used to
house his teacher he said and by her
passing but knows that that's what she
wanted he'll then disappear from the
archives never to be seen again unless
you manage to find her way to the Blue
Lake in which you'll find him sitting
alone by the shore earlier in your
journey Coral mentioned how he wanted to
see where the rain came from in the city
of tears and he seems to have found it
you can join coral and relaxer for as
long as you want but leaving in return
will see him disappear once again with
the sword stuck on the ground implying
that he's completed his journey and
moved on where he plans to go next is
unclear and will likely never be known
but similar to my thoughts on corniver
it was always nice to catch up with
quarrel every now and then and be able
to listen to his thoughts on the
hollownest he's a very likable character
easily one of my favorites in the game
and being able to fight together even if
it was only once was a great way to end
his questline
after manamon is lower Again The Watcher
they're located at the top of the city
of Tears in a building they called the
Watcher's Spire given the location of
their room it seems like Lurgan was
someone within hollowness High Society
possibly one of the more popular ones
given that they have a tower all to
themselves
unlike manoman Lurgan didn't seem to
have some kind of grand plan as they
just decided to do this out of the
kindness of their heart as he cared
about hollownest and its City blocking
us from reaching him though are the
Watcher Knights a large army of knights
who were tasked with guarding lerium
with their lives oddly enough all of
them are dead by the time we arrive so
it seems like they never left the room
and then slowly died over time meaning
they just left his quarters wide open
for us to get to however I guess they
did succeed in defending lurian until
their dying breath so mission
accomplished I guess sadly it's not
going to be as simple as that though as
something comes from the ceiling and
reanimates the Knights to fight again
judging from its orange color scheme it
seems to be connected to the infection
but it's never explained after their
defeat we could finally meet with Lorien
and just like manaman go into the dream
room and absorb their Essence I know
that was a bit fast and I was surprised
too as the other dreamers had at least
something timed them back to the world
but lorgan really just seems to be a
person in the city who wanted to do some
good our final dreamer is Hera the Beast
she's located deep in the Deep Nest as
she at the time was the leader of her
people as We Know the Deep Nest belongs
to the Weavers in the spider tribe but
we also know that most of the Kingdom
didn't like them and the mantises under
the order of The Pale King we're tasked
with keeping them away from the rest of
the Kingdom this just shows how
desperate the King was to stop the
infection as he went to the one tribe
that hated him the most in order to work
something out after lots of negotiating
hair eventually agreed to become a
dreamer but only if the pilgrim agreed
to have a child with her and from
numerous pieces of dialogue and thanks
to her literally appearing shortly after
killing hero we learned that this child
was Hornet it's never explicitly stated
why Hera wanted a child but given that
her partner died at some point prior
it's possible that she just wanted one
it's quote unfortunate though that she
didn't get much time if any to spend
with hornik given that hero was then
sent into the dream shortly after but
like lorian she wanted to make sure the
world was a better place not just for
her people but for her eventual child
this funny enough also means that Hornet
is old as as well we don't know how
long it's been since the hollow Knight
was sealed we could assume it was a very
long time ago also speaking of funny
ages the other bug despite being called
that is probably one of the young
longest bugs in the game as he remarks
how he's never seen the Stag stations
before as they were closed before he
arrived but they closed once the
infection started spreading so he's
actually quite young in comparison to
the others of the hollowness and even
younger than the Knight given their
origin to get to her though we have to
do a bit more work than before the core
of the deep Nest is a giant open room
filled with spider webs one of the rooms
has numerous corpses being strung up or
tied together which connects to the room
right next door is these villagers
encourage us to sit down only to tie us
up once we do I don't recall the game
ever mentioning anything about these
beings outside of this one interaction
but it's possible that they're the
spiders of the deep Nest using a
disguise within the deepness the player
may come across another Knight wandering
around if you manage to follow them all
the way through their nest you'll be
trapped and attacked by NOS who has
disguised itself as the knight in order
to lure us into their lair
it's possible that these villagers are
also just disguises used to lure other
bugs into the deep Nest which explains
why we find so many carcasses in the
other room additionally we could find
the bodies of the villagers after we
escape their trap and they're laid out
in a manner that implies that it's a
costume or cloak of some kind instead of
an actual body now that we're trapped
though we need to break free and by
doing so and reaching the end of this
maze we can find the body of Hera just
like before all we have to do is go into
the dream and absorb her Essence but now
that all the dreamers are dead the
temple is open and we can go inside but
upon arrival you'll notice that
something's changed the crossroads has
become infected and new enemies along
with infected versions of old ones on
pollute the streets this event occurs
after the death of Warren dreamer or if
we acquire the Monarch Wings which have
us fighting a boss called the broken
vessel in order to reach it this seems
to be another being similar to the
Knight that was killed but is now being
puppeteered by the infection this is all
basically an attempt to make an early
game area much harder as by now most of
the enemies die in one or two hits but
it's also a good way of showing how easy
it is for the infection to spread as
well as how close the infection is to
breaking out of the hollow Knight
well this is definitely a cause for
concern it should be something we do
right away we aren't going to do that
and instead attend the circus
[Music]
foreign
after the release of hollow Knight 4
DLCs were released for the game two of
them were more gameplay focused called
Hidden Dreams and lifeblood with the
other two being more story focused than
the Grim troop and godmaster the Grim
troop first starts in the howling Cliffs
and is activated by strike in this
Brazier hidden in a secret room this
calls a few new people to dirtmouth who
make the Elder bug uncomfortable anyone
who scares the other bugs immediately on
my hit list so let's go see what these
clowns have to say for themselves well
apparently clown wasn't far off as the
Grim Trooper are traveling band of
circus performers except they only seen
to perform for their own people and only
have one act which is centered around
the main head of the troop Grim he has
one of the best opening acts I've ever
seen in which he gives us custody of his
child tells us to raise it and then
disappears I guess you could call me the
new stepfather but I'm really just the
father who stepped up nevertheless to
raise this child they must equip the new
charm Grim child and then take it to
various points throughout hollana store
to capture the Flames located there
these will always have some kind of
enemy that we have to defeat so there's
at least some level of challenge here
the issue is that this is all we do for
most of the DLC we we grab three Flames
from hollownest go back to Grim get
three more return to him fight Grim grab
three more and then choose our ending
it's not exactly the most stimulating
experience out there but I do recognize
that this would have been better suited
to do throughout the playthrough usually
for my videos I record the DLCs after
the main content is done so as to
organize my recordings in fact at this
point in the playthrough I had already
done the three main endings of the game
so this was all I had left to do this
decision ended up making the DLC a chore
to go through as it's the same nonsense
over and over again which is why I think
doing this along with the other content
would create a much better experience
it's best to treat the groomtube not as
a DLC but just as another mystery within
hollowness to uncover as you go is it
will feel a lot better than spending 20
minutes going back and forth picking up
all the flames regarding those Flames
what these are are basically the Flames
of a kingdom the groom troop seems to go
to the kingdoms that have long since
passed and collect these Eternal Scarlet
Flames they then use these flames in the
ritual which is what Grim is having us
do for him it feels a little odd to kill
Grim's own people to gather these as I
feel like a simple conversation could
avoid any unnecessary Bloodshed but
given how this DLC ends it's rare to
assume that Grim is doing this to make
sure the child is ready and prepared as
giving it the tools it needs to grow
without struggle would hinder its growth
this is also another reason why I think
doing this DLC along with the rest of
the content is a much better option as
you actually get time to use the Grim
child and experiment with their
different forms unlike me where I had it
for maybe 30 minutes at most once we
come back a second time Grimm will thank
us for helping and have us take part in
an upcoming act he's performing which
means we have a boss to fight Grimm has
no plans on dying here just like Hornet
as he's just gauging our strength and
making sure the child is worthy kind of
a shame we can't actually use the child
in the fight though as it's required to
start the duel with grim but then he
just takes the child back meaning we're
also wasting a couple notches in the
process over overall Grim himself wasn't
too difficult and I found him to be very
mechanically engaging like most of the
bosses but I was a much bigger fan of
his other version after Gathering the
last set of flames he'd come across Brum
another member of The Troop who tells us
that if we want to send the Grim troop
away we can stop the ritual this leads
to two endings one where we stop the
troop and another where we continue the
ritual judging from the ritual ending it
seems like all the members of The Troop
survey higher being located in the dream
realm it doesn't seem like the troop is
allied with the being though as they
seem to be partaking in the ritual
against their own will as evidenced by
Brum asking if we want to stop the thing
they literally came here to do the
ritual itself seems to be how the higher
being sustains itself and continues its
life cycle but most of the details
behind it are unclear in fact quite a
lot of this DLC is actually unclear
which is probably my biggest issue with
it as it feels like it ends too quickly
I came out of this DLC not with
satisfaction but more confusion as I was
still trying to figure out what was even
going on here the banishment ending sees
us just stopping the ritual by striking
the Brazier again which is in odd way to
end things given we just killed or
stopped a God by hitting a pot but okay
which is Then followed up by the troop
disappearing in an NPC named Nim seeking
Refuge here in dirt mouth this is very
clearly brung from before but without
their previous memories as they claim to
not know where they are or how they got
here the ritual ending has this
challenge nightmare Kane Grimm a
stronger version of the original Grimm
who upon death seems to disappear along
with the troop judging by the design of
the groom child and the various sources
of info it seems like the groom child
took the essence of grim and will
eventually become the new Grim only to
be eaten by the next grandchild
repeating the cycle it's a cliffhanger
type ending but not one that feels
satisfying in any way to be fair
Cliffhangers aren't meant to be
satisfying but it goes back to what I
said earlier it felt like we were just
getting into the meat of this thing only
for it to end right when it was getting
good there is no fight against this
higher being no section where we talked
with or even really do anything which is
a shame that being said the one thing
that does at least Warren some
discussion is one of Grim's dream nail
dialogues which talks about The Pale
King and the Knight more specifically
referring to the Knight as a vessel
which is something that will make more
sense when we talk about the ending
shortly but it seems to imply that Grim
knows of the other higher beings likely
because of his relationship with his
higher being regardless I think the good
ending in this context would have to be
the banishment ending as it's very clear
that the troop is being used by the
higher being to extend its life so by
stopping that we prevent the true from
being manipulated and the higher being
who started this either has to find the
New Kingdom to pillage or will die
thanks to us stopping it that being said
though I'm not a huge fan of the
banishment ending because doing so means
you'll miss probably the best fight in
the whole game Nightmare King Grim is my
favorite boss in Hollow Knight due to
how intense the flight was he's one of
those bosses that doesn't have a lot of
stuff surrounding him meaning all you
have to do is learn his moves and then
counter-attack every time until he's
dead this became a bit of an issue
though as nightmare Kane Grimm is not
only faster and harder to kill but his
moves change as well one of his most
common moves is this bad attack in the
original fight all you have to do is
double jump over the three allowing you
to dodge all the bats and get him one or
two hits him before he disappears with
the nightmare version though he not only
sends four bats at you but their
position in a way that will punish you
for double jumping and instead what
you're meant to do is jump once right
when the first bat passes over you then
Dodge forward allowing you to reach Grim
without taking damage
became a bit of a problem for me as I
had to not only unlearn my old habits
from fighting original Grim but also
learn new habits involved with nightmare
grin to make matters worse he is I
believe one of two bosses in the game to
do a minimum two masks of damage instead
of one the game also lets you know
things are getting real serious now
because instead of his name appearing in
the bottom corner like all the other
bosses his name takes up the whole
screen once you defeat Grim though he
then ends up disappearing along with the
rest of the troop thanks to them
completing the ritual like I said it's a
bit of a quick ending as I felt like
things were about to get good but then
it ends overall though I enjoyed the DLC
as a short little Side Story that occurs
alongside the night's journey I do wish
more was mentioned regarding the troop
as it's unclear what we even did in
either ending and given that it's a DLC
I have my doubts that this will ever be
mentioned in a sequel and assuming
that's true it ends up making the Grim
true about to be a faction and DLC that
kind of leaves you scratching your head
wondering what you even did
with the circus out of business we can
now return to the task at hand and take
the flight to the hollow Knight upon
stepping into the black egg we're then
greeted to an extremely dark room only
being lit up thanks to the pillars that
appear as we walk after walking through
the large hallway we enter the room that
houses the hollow Knight upon breaking
his binds he immediately attacks us
seeing as the infection is slowly taking
over the room along with him it's clear
he isn't in control of his actions but
there does still seem to be some amount
of him left as he'll stab himself
throughout the fight it's kind of
horrifying in a way actually watching
this being battle his own mind while
simultaneously killing you and himself
just goes to show how deadly this
infection is and how much pain the
holiday is in because of it assuming you
can get through all of his phases you
strike the hollow Knight one last time
which has him crying out in pain as the
night like the dreamers consumes his
Essence the Knight will then take up the
mantle as vessel and replace the hollow
Knight containing the infection within
its body thus saving the hollownest but
also repeating the cycle of Torment as
only a matter of time Until It Breaks
free again it's a pretty sad ending and
not exactly satisfying for many reasons
one of which being that the game told me
that I didn't achieve 100 completion so
I knew that there was still more to go
but more importantly Hornet never showed
up despite being quite the pivotal
character it seems she didn't make
another appearance after defeating Hera
meaning we still have more to do hollow
Knight's endings tie back into that
exploration side of the story The More
You explore the more you learn and by
getting this ending it shows that we
didn't learn anything we may have
learned about hollowness but we haven't
learned about us and our role in all
this so we need to keep looking
fortunately there are two more endings
for us to find what prompts the
activation of the second ending is the
acquisition of an item called the void
heart which is an item called the king
soul that is Tainted by the power of the
Void but the king's soul is put into two
and needs to be meted together by
acquiring both pieces that are kept by
our two rulers the white lady and The
Pale King the queen is located in the
Queen's Garden who thankfully gives us
the first half upon talking to her as I
mentioned earlier she liked to come here
is a sort of home away from home but the
traders in moskin didn't take too kindly
to as they say a pale one intruding on
their land so they attempted to kill her
dryer one of the Five Knights was able
to hold off all those that would inflict
harm upon her but it came at the cost of
her own life the white lady is hard to
talk talk about though she doesn't
really display any sort of magical
powers she is most definitely a higher
being like The Pale King but we don't
really know what she can do one thing we
do know is that these Bindings that are
wrapped around her were of her own
volition according to her she has The
Sensational urge to spread her seed and
breed but she regrets her recent
Endeavors and as such bound herself
together these Bunnings may also be
weakening her in some way as her
strength is not what it used to be as
she has trouble seeing right in front of
her this specific regret though is tied
to The Pale King who will meet very
shortly to get to him and to understand
his role in all this we need the king's
brain and the awoken dream now this more
powerful version of the dream now is
only accessible after giving Seer 1800
essence you can collect Essence in this
game either fighting the warrior dreams
fighting the repeat dream bosses like
dung Defender result and collecting
these orbs in these dream routes neither
of these though will provide you with
enough Essence on its own so it's
recommended that you dabble in each in
order to acquire the necessary amount
this awakened version allows us to go
into the ancient Basin and dream nail
this dead kingsguard this takes us to
the White Palace the home of The Pale
King originally this Palace used to
exist in the physical world right where
we just were but once the infection hit
the king gathered his top subjects and
teleported into the dream realm away
from all the chaos of the hollownest the
White Palace as the name suggests is
extremely white and covered in shiny
ordained pillars and Towers it's also
got a few people from hollownest in here
only talk about the king and their wand
to serve him to get to the king we need
to go through an obstacle course of
traps that are filled with spikes and
saw blades which makes me wonder why the
king even has guards in the first place
says this is more than enough to stop
anyone from finding him except of course
us as we're the knighting we can do
anything upon arriving to the king's
quarters though we can see that he's
been dead for quite a while the contrast
of the room is very well done as
everything so far has been bright and
holy but the actual bed chambers of the
king himself are the darkest part of the
palace thanks to him being dead though
we can't get anything out of him except
one dream nail dialogue that says no
cost too great which connects to where
we go next at the bottom of the king's
edges where we find our next item the
king brand but stopping us is Hornet who
is once again here to test our strength
and see if we're worthy of continuing
she warns us that continuing further
will only bring about Dark Truth and
it's one that weak-minded individuals
cannot bear to learn I do want to
clarify Hornet seems to have no qualms
of killing us as she doesn't want to
Ally herself with a weakling so it's not
like Graham where they have a plan that
involves us hornet will gladly carry on
without us and do things her way that
being said I do believe dying is canon
in these games as we leave behind a
shade that we can kill in order to get
our stuff back and Confessor Gigi is
based around this mechanic as they can
summon our shade for us so it does seem
like dying is a part of our journey
although I'm still unsure of that fact
myself regardless once you defeat Hornet
you will finally realize that we're
strong enough to continue and that
teaming up would prove beneficial to her
that's because Hornet will save us once
we enter what's behind her this show is
actually the remnants of The Pale King
when he first arrived in what would
become hollownest the pill King is
considered a worm and death to them is
not a symbol AS dying but more so
shedding their skin and becoming a
different version of their original Self
the pill King was presumably as large as
this shell implies but thanks to them
shedding his skin he's now a lot smaller
the reason we're here though is that the
king's brand is inside its shell and is
going to be used to unlock a specific
door in the ancient Basin upon picking
it up though the shell starts to crumble
and collapses on the night before Horner
comes by to drag them out further
confirming that she now sees us as a
worthy Ally with the king's brand in
hand we can now go to the giant door
locked in the ancient Basin that locked
away the abyss the abyss is a very dark
location filled with sharp spikes a
black void and hundreds of masks and
shades similar to that of our Knight
within here is also a large creature
holding a bowl filled with black liquid
I'm still not entirely sure what's up
with this specific individual but there
are quite a few creatures like this
throughout the game like these statues
gameplay-wise they give a soul that we
can use for spells and for health but
they've seen a point to an ancient
civilization that existed long before
the pale King's arrival a civilization
that may have worshiped the void that
permeates this location but while the
kings run allowed us access to the whole
area a specific location inside the
abyss is only accessible thanks to the
king's Soul this leads us to a giant
black egg that upon hitting it takes us
into a flashback we see the knight at
the bottom of the Abyss attempting to
climb back up to the door that we
entered through while text continues to
flash on screen saying things like no
mind to think or no will to break this
enzoid to reached top in which we see
The Pale King in another night leaving
the abyss before closing the door
forever what this tells us is that the
Knight was born here in the abyss and is
made of the void and that these other
people we've come across are our
siblings furthermore the shape of the
sibling's head is eerily similar to the
hollow Knights meaning he too is our
brother so with the biggest Twist of the
story now revealed it's finally time to
talk about what's going on here years
ago The Pale King came to this land to
die until it shed its skin and took on
its new form he then decided to give his
power to his people causing them to see
him as a God after some time the kingdom
of hollownest was born but soon after
came the infection it swept across the
land taking over people's minds and
seeping into their dreams the king along
with his Queen the white lady attempted
to stop this Threat by creating the
vessels the vessels are the Knight and
their siblings their whole purpose was
to be for a lack of a better word a box
that seals the infection away the
dialogue that talked about no mind to
think and no will to break was
referencing the vessels that's why the
Knight can't talk or feel emotion as
these are things that the infection
could manipulate the king and the white
lady made hundreds if not thousands of
these beings in order to find the
perfect vessel eventually the pill can
determined that the hollow Knight was
the one so he came to the abyss took him
from his siblings and locked away all
the trash now the game never explains
why the hollow Knight specifically was
the chosen one but I wonder if it has to
do with the abyss itself as this place
has a pain in the ass to get out of and
that's with the tools we found like
double jumping dashes and wall climb
things the vessels don't have so it's my
theory that the Pale King chose the
hollow Knight because he was the first
one to escape the abyss this could also
explain the hundreds of bodies on the
floor as the vessels could have possibly
been climbing on top of each other in
order to escape another thing that's
also not explained is the door itself is
The Pale King clearly locked the vessels
away yet some of them including us
managed to escape I sadly don't have any
theories this time as this door is the
only way out and required the king's
brand to open so your guess is as good
as mine
as an extra layer of safety though The
Pale King put the hollow Knight in the
black gay Temple and sealed that using
Lurie and Hera and manamon who later
became known as the dreamers now that we
know our true origin the first thing we
need to consider is our relationship
with the Hornet and zote as I mentioned
earlier both are similar to The Knight
design wise with zoping the more obvious
of the two since Hornet was conceived by
The Pale King and Hera that makes Hornet
our stepsibling she isn't a vessel like
we are but she is related to us through
The Pale King as for zote I don't think
he's a vessel for the simple fact that
he could speak and think whether or not
he intentionally created an outfit to
look like the other siblings and the
Knight is unclear and also very zote but
I don't think zote is meant to be a
vessel circling back to the hollow
Knight though we have to ask the obvious
question what the hell happened he was
supposed to be the perfect vessel so how
did it fail well it was actually the
pale King's own doing inside the White
Palace is one of the most annoying
platforming puzzles in the whole game
called the path of pain but if you can
somehow cross it without wanting to tear
your hair out it'll be shown another
flashback of the hollow Knight and The
Pale King resting in the White Palace
The Pale King thought of the hollow
Knight as his own son which is
technically true but this caused the
hollow Knight to gain emotions and
feelings something it wasn't supposed to
have which is why the infection started
spreading that's also why the first
ending is still considered sad and
ultimately pointless as we too have
gained emotions and feelings thanks to
us interacting with the NPCs all this
circles back to the introduction of the
game though the Knight was summoned here
by the call of the hollow Knight to
fulfill its purpose seal the infection
and protect hollownest but is that the
only way well
let's find out returning back to the
temple we find a hornet who tells us
that she'll Aid us in our fight against
the hollow Knight but can only stay for
a short time as the void within the egg
would kill her further proving that she
was not made to be a vessel the boss
fight continues as normal until the
Final Phase which he's Hornet tying down
the hollow Knight and giving us an
opening its head is also surrounded by
dream Essence but if you somehow miss
this clue Hornet will pass out and the
flight continues defeating the hollow
Knight now sees Hornet locked inside the
egg with her mask being put on the
outside of the temple implying that
she's now a dreamer while the night once
again becomes the new vessel for the
infection once again not an amazing
ending and definitely not the final one
as we still have one more thing to do if
we instead Drew know the hollow Knight
we go into its mind to find the source
of the infection
thank you
[Applause]
inside the hollow Knight was the
radiance a higher being and also the
creator of the infection that is
infested hollownest to add to our
previous talk when The Pale King arrived
and became a God we know that Sear's
ancestors The Moth tribe forsook the
radiance in favor of The Pale King well
the radiance in an attention-seeking
attempt to seek attention decided to use
her powers as a way to influence the
bugs of hollownest those dreams
envisions all the citizens we're seeing
was because the radiance wanted itself
to be known many of its residents
resisted these thoughts and this
resistance resulted in the manifestation
of the infection it seems like the
radiance believed that if the people
wouldn't accept and worship her
willingly then she would do it by force
The Pale King after hearing word of this
infection attempted to stop it and well
we know the rest but now as the night
where tasks would stop in the infection
at the source and putting this thing to
rest once and for all one thing I'm a
real sucker for that Hollow Knight uses
quite a bit is making the story or
fights based around Concepts and ideas
the pill can blessed the bugs of Islam
with the ability to think but the
radiance wants to regress its
inhabitants back to their original more
primitive States is they would be easier
to control as you can see there are
goals for the people of hollownest are
Polar Opposites the radiance is also a
warrior that wields light while the
Knight wields the powers of the Void two
substances that would be at odds of one
another in fact you might even say that
they are the embodiments of these
Concepts as the radiance is the
brightest being in existence as far as
we know and is presumably responsible
for the creation of essence while the
Knight is a being born of void who also
thinks the void heart item we got
earlier just reunited the void under him
which is why the void slowly starts to
creep into the boss fight like I said
I'm a real sucker for this stuff as it
makes it more than just a boss fight to
me as the forces of dark and light are
literally coming together to do battle
with one another unfortunately though
the radiance is too strong for the
Knight on their own however she is
unaware of the siblings waiting down
below that are waiting for their time to
strike
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
the Knight evolves its original shade
form and becomes something else entirely
using its new void-like powers to strike
the radiance while the shade of the
hollow Knight holds it down and with
that the radiance is defeated hollownest
is saved the infection is no more Hornet
is alive and the siblings including the
Knight have served their purpose and can
now finally rest
talk about an ending it's beautiful and
the music really tuggles on the
heartstrings a bit is we could finally
say that after all the deaths and
failures we did it we won it's such a
wonderful ending it is my favorite in
the game from the quest it took to get
here to the boss fight itself to the
final rush to the end while the siblings
all weight in anticipation ready to back
us up it's a fantastic ending and a
wonderful and a hollow knight story
except it wouldn't be as one more DLC
would release that ends up sort of
soiling this otherwise great ending
a year and a half after release steam
Cherry the people behind the game would
release the final piece of content for
hollow Knight titled godmaster which not
only added a wealth of new content but
also two new endings the best way to
describe godmaster is to say that it's a
tale of two extremes itok would made
Hollow Knight's gameplay so much fun and
put it together in a neatly wrapped
package yet despite recognizing A
mid-hollow Knight's gameplay so fun to
play it clearly didn't recognize him at
its original story so fun to learn as it
applies none of those same methods of
Storytelling here in the DLC it first
starts in the junk pit underneath the
city of Tears in here is a new NPC
called The godseeker Who upon dream
nailing will send us to its home app we
name the god home from here the players
left to their own devices and you can
immediately tell that this is a Boss
Rush DLC through and through there are
initially three pantheons which after
being completed will unlock a fourth
which upon its completion will lock the
fifth and final Pantheon for the player
to participate in each one has a set
number of bosses from the main game that
get increasingly more difficult with the
first Pantheon having bosses like the
vengefly king and Hornet so the fourth
one containing the likes of numerous
Warrior dreams in dream bosses each of
them have 10 bosses each with a fifth
one being the ultimate test as it's the
previous four put together in addition
to adding newer bosses like nightmare
Kane grim and changes to previous boss
fights like the vengefly king who is now
joined by a second one in this specific
version to add insult to injury all of
them must be done without dying while
the game does have benches usually
halfway through the pantheon that allow
to regain your health and soul back as
well as respect your charms they aren't
save points like in the main game if
you're up for even more challenge you
can also add bindings to the doors such
as less damage or no spells due to this
level of difficulty though you're likely
going to struggle fortunately the game
has another room called the Hall of Gods
which lets you challenge every boss in
the game each of them also has three
difficulties which you can track using a
board at the front door attuned is the
basic default difficulty ascended is a
slightly harder version of the original
difficulty and radiant is the previous
difficulty along with the ever so small
caveat that you die in one hit it is as
difficult as it sounds but it would be
an understatement to say that there is a
lot of content here you could be here
for over 10 to 20 hours just going
through everything and clearly team
Cherry knew that the community would
want to play this more because they made
a game mode specifically for this DLC
after unlocking the fourth Pantheon you
also gain access to the godseeker mode
which gives you all the charms nail
upgrades spells and masks but you can't
leave the god home it's supposed to be
for those that want to play the dlc's
content but don't want to go through a
whole 30 plus hour playthrough just to
get prepared for it like I said it takes
everything that makes Hollow Knight's
gameplay so good and puts it all
together in one DLC and I had a blast
going through the pantheons and
practicing on the bosses that I
struggled with but its story is what
really dragged down the experience here
it's hard to really call it a story as
similar to the previous DLC you don't
even know what you're doing here and
you're giving even less answers as to
what's going on the godseeker is a large
bean that presumably locked itself
inside of a coffin so that it wouldn't
be disturbed that's because the
godseekers people all live inside the
god home dream realm they basically put
other people's minds into one being and
it's thanks to this that they're able to
conjure up the dream realm with ease at
the beginning though the godseeker is
incoherent and will stay this way until
we go through the pantheons that's
because is the god Seeker wants to
attune to the gods of the hollownest
which in layman's terms are the bosses
we fight in the pantheons you can think
of each boss as a rung on a ladder and
we're slowly climbing higher and higher
until we reach the top that's why the
bosses slowly get harder across the
pantheons as the godseeker needs more
strength than the last to ascend higher
so to help the godseeker Ascend we have
to do all the pantheons and I do mean
all of them yeah the ending of this DLC
is locked behind the 42 boss brush
Pantheon Hollow Knight is definitely a
difficult game there is no doubt about
that but I'd argue this is too difficult
only because the story content is locked
behind something that's mostly designed
for gameplay purposes
but even if we're to ignore the
difficulty why is the story tied to this
admittedly I don't play many games with
Boss Rush modes and even the ones that
do I'm not too interested in doing so so
maybe this is a common thing but I've
never seen a game tied story to
something like this before and that's
probably because it doesn't make sense
to the godseeker only appears during the
pantheons when you have to go through
all of them just to speak with them and
even then their dialogue is as tedious
as the pantheons themselves your first
meeting with them is in the second last
room of the first Pantheon and it goes
about as you would expect the godseeker
scold you for being in their domain and
tells you to leave immediately lest we
want Divine punishment to be struck down
upon us this same dialogue is basically
repeated throughout the other pantheons
as well there are three places where the
godseeker can talk to us which are
before the pantheon starts the second to
last room of the pantheon and then out
by the junk pit but they only have new
dialogue when you complete one so in
order of events you'll listen to them in
the beginning battle through the bosses
listen to them towards the end beat it
and then talk to them at the Jung pit
you'll be repeating this four times for
the four pantheons yet at no point does
the dialogue ever change it's the same
thing just in a different font It's All
About Us and how we are ruining their
plans and how the gods of the Holiness
should kill us as a result we are 80 of
the way through this story and all we've
gained is a hater what immediately
confused me though were these talks
because the godseeker makes it
explicitly clear that they attuned to
the minds of the bosses through ritual
combat but isn't that what we're doing
if anything aren't we helping them we
don't see the god Seekers fighting nor
do we see the bosses fight each other so
it seems like they're just lounging
around doing nothing until we showed up
I will say though it seems like the
bosses are conscious enough to recognize
where they are as Grim bows to the
godseeker and Hornet's stream nail
dialogue talks about whether she's in
her dream or in ours but seeing his
Hornet never talks about this outside of
the DLC and no other characters mention
something like this it's kind of
pointless to talk about either way the
reason we're doing this is because the
god Seekers have an obsession with gods
they used to be from a place called the
land of storms but after their gods
abandoned them they left to go find
something else to serve this is when
they decided to merge into one being as
it was easier for them to travel and
their combined knowledge managed to
create the God only all inhabit the
reason they came here is because the
mask they wear is used to find the
essence of great warriors and hollownest
is supposedly filled with them so
they're hoping to use this in order to
ascend the godseekers are basically
trying to be hollowness biggest dick
riders as communing with what they call
the god of gods located here will allow
them to ascend to their Highest
Potential what this God of gods is at
the moment is unknown but once you
arrive to the fourth Pantheon the
godseeker will talk about the boss in
the Next Room being the last one they
need to attune to in order to find their
God of gods and seeing as this boss is
the pure vessel a perfected version of
the hollow Knight this God of gods is
likely the radiance this is then pretty
much confirmed in the final Pantheon as
the radiance is now called the absolute
Radiance who is the final boss of the
pantheon but can only be fought in that
final fifth Pantheon as you can see the
storytelling if we can call it that is
almost non-existent as we're forced to
play through these incredibly tedious
rooms just to get the same dialogue set
in different words it's holding until
the 5th Pantheon where things seem to
start to go somewhere but ultimately
that doesn't end well either instead of
showing up once the godseeker finally
gets their act together and shows up a
few more times now while also showing us
visions of various higher beings within
Hollow Nest mainly un the white lady in
The Pale King but their dialogue is once
again pointless all the godseeker does
is comment on the beings themselves and
sometimes ask itself questions which
oddly enough we know the answers to the
godseeker talks about on and says that
they can feel their strength weighing
and that they must have been pretty
strong back in the day they also comment
on the white lady's lack of strength and
ask why she is hiding from them likely
referencing her lack of power and how
their Mass can't detect her which we
know is thanks to The Binding she put on
herself in regards to The Pale King they
mentioned once again how they can feel
its power emanating from its body but
wonder why he took on the form he did as
the godseeker claims that they would
have gotten more devotees by being a
bigger being but we know why The Pale
King did this and that was because they
were dying and worms like him shed their
skin as a former rebirth so four-fifths
of this DLC is spent listening to this
being berate us over and over again with
the last of it having us listen to it
try to come up with answers to questions
we already know like I said the actual
story telling here is questionable at
best and what makes matters worse is
that this is the last time we will talk
to the godseeker as in the Next Room is
the absolute Radiance who upon its
defeat will trigger the ending I also
want to clarify this is an actual ending
not one like the Grim tube where it's a
DLC ending I mean a proper End Game
ending as it sends you back to before
you completed the pantheon just like the
main game sends you back to before you
beat the hollow Knight and you also get
a thank you from Team Cherry in a
completion screen just like the main
game too this is an actionable ending to
hollow knight story and that's my
biggest gripe with this DLC because in
what way is this tied to the events of
the game the only items required to be
this DLC are the dream now which is
needed to under the god home and the
void heart which we need to start the
final Pantheon these are the only items
you need which aren't locked behind any
of the dreamers or the hollow Knight me
meaning you can get an official ending
to the game Hollow Knight with ever
interacting with the dreamers or
defeating the boss in which the game is
named after now technically we do fight
the hollow Knight and the radiance and
the pantheons but we are also in the
dream realm that's also partially in the
mind of a being who locked itself on a
coffin at the bottom of the City sewers
we could it be further from the
hollownest if we tried then there's also
the fact that godseeker mode is Canon
somehow as it takes place after the
ending as the godsuga becomes
uncomfortably hard to listen to given
that they see us as their new God of
gods even though as we're about to see
we either kill the godseeker or teleport
away from the kingdom and neither of
which make a whole lot of sense to me
outside of the fact that they have now
gone from dick riding the radiance to
dick riding us furthermore this all
circles back to my earlier comment about
when it made Hollow Knight's main story
so interesting as that sense of
exploration is gone here we don't
explore anything besides this one room
we only talk to One NPC and the only
things we fight or find are bosses that
we've already met it's everything that
the main game is not and the fact that
this DLC has an official ending yet
doesn't require the player to actually
engage with the main game in any way is
the cherry on top here as for the
endings themselves they're basically the
same but change depending on if you gave
the godseeker the delicate flower this
is something that we can get from zamir
and the resting grounds originally we're
supposed to Planet at the grave of their
lover which is the trailer Lord's child
but once that happens it sprouts
allowing us to give it to more NPCs the
first one you should definitely give it
to is the elder bug who is extremely
delighted to receive it and will keep it
with him forever but we can also give
this to the godseeker this changes the
ending as without it the Knight becomes
a void entity that the community has
called the shade Lord and completely
destroys the radiance but this entity is
now running loose in the god home and
takes the opportunity to cover the
godseeker in void and presumably kill it
what if it has the flower it's able to
protect the godseeker and instead
teleports it and possibly the shade Lord
away to an unknown destination zamir and
a couple NPCs tell us that the flower
comes from an unknown Place far away
from here so maybe this will get touched
upon in silk song but for now we're
unsure of its true power either way the
radiance dies in bold endings meaning
the infection is gone as the veins
around the egg Temple lose their orange
color it also seems to have reverted
anyone infected back to their original
forms as Horna is seen walking its Halls
before being approached by a mysterious
being that looks like the hollow Knight
judging by the curved mask and nail
this in all fairness did get me pretty
excited as the hollow Knight possibly
being alive in the night being the
literal void itself is an interesting
idea that I would like to see elaborated
on in silk song but the methods that it
took to get here were just not
interesting enough for me to justify
this that's why I think the third ending
with the original Radiance is better as
it feels like an actual conclusion
everything makes sense we destroyed the
radiance at the source saved hollownest
and used our siblings to kill the
radiance but in here we meet a random
NPC fought through an extremely tedious
Gauntlet of the same bosses for hours
and then the Knight Kills the radians
through this ritual saves hollowness
then becomes the embodiment of the Void
nothing really felt answered or resolved
and it arguably leaves more questions
and answers which is not uncommon for
endings like this but it is possible to
make an ending that resolves the current
game while setting up the next one and
that's exactly what ending 3 did the
godmaster endings just add more
questions without any answers I do like
the night being a void entity and I like
the idea of the hollow Knight and Hornet
possibly teaming up but all of that is
complete speculation as especially when
you consider that Silk song takes place
in a completely different Kingdom so
that also begs the question of whether
or not any of this will even be answered
to repeat what I said at the top of this
section the godmaster is a tale of two
extremes gameplay wise it's some of the
best content in the game and I can
easily see myself sinking more hours
into this after I finish this video
story wise though at best it's mildly
interesting and at worst I almost wish
it didn't have a story tied to it its
method of Storytelling is tedious the
main NPC of the DLC refused to elaborate
on anything and barely interacts with
the player at all and the endings take
away from the previous set of Endings by
making these the Canon ones in all
fairness it's not clear what endings are
actually Canon for hollow Knight but I
find it odd that team Cherry would just
add new endings for no reason especially
after the main game is already out they
did this with the grimchu DLC but that
was only for that DLC these are official
endings which makes me believe that they
had these endings in mind as the Canon
option since they were added in after
the fact and that's a real shame as
climbing the realm with our siblings and
defeating the radiance alongside horn
and the hollow Knight was a perfect
ending to this game a godmaster kind of
ruins that
Hollow Knight is a wonderful
metroidvania with an extremely
interesting story that has me very
excited for silk song obviously I was
critical of a few Key Parts but if my
biggest complaint was one DLC I think
we're in good hands here plus that's
also just one small slice of this
incredibly large game that's also not
even considering the fact that this was
free too team Cherry now only charged 15
at most for this game but never asked
for another Cent more after its release
which is kind of insane to me given that
this game needed money via Kickstarter
to even exist I honestly would not have
been surprised how they asked for money
for these DLCs but team Cherry refused
and it shows the amount of passion they
have for this game they couldn't have
made this game without its backers and
not only did they want to make sure that
they and their future buyers were happy
with their purchase they also wanted to
pay homage to those that gave this game
the legs it needed as littered all
throughout the game as backer created
content bosses like the god Tamer and
all the warrior dreams were initially
created by fans NPCs like cloth and
militia and tiso were backer created
content and there's an entire location
called the spirits glaive which serves
as a cemetery for hollowness that also
has loads of bugs created by the backers
regardless of my thoughts on the call of
those NPCs or bosses the mere concept of
having your creation put into a game is
extremely cool and the fact that team
Cherry was willing to do this on
multiple occasions shows how much
passion they have for the game and their
Community I can say without a doubt that
this is the best 15 you'll ever spend in
your life as there is enough content
here to make it easily worth your
purchase and even if you play this game
one time Hollow Knight's story will
easily be able to Captivate you the same
way it did to me exploring hollownest
was a joy and going through a new area
always felt like a fresh Adventure as I
wonder what would be around the corner
would it be a boss an MPC an item all or
tablet I didn't know but I was always
eager to find out
halona is at its best when it has you
wanting more which may have had the
unintended side effect of me wanting a
bit too much as the way for silk song
now begins if the trailers are anything
to go off of those silk song is shaping
up to be a beautiful entry in this
series I don't know when it's going to
come out but like the siblings of the
Abyss I'll be waiting patiently in the
darker cave that is my room until
release hoping that unlike The Pale King
the team won't close it off from the
rest of the world never to be seen again
thanks for watching
thank you for watching today and I hope
you enjoyed many of you likely remember
that I promised this video a while ago I
had some issues making it the first time
around but I'm glad it's finally done
also I want to shout out Lily who made
this absolutely adorable piece of
artwork for the announcement of the
video I highly recommend you check her
out especially if you're a fan art of
anything related to the souls games as
she has a ton of it she was incredibly
easy to work with and I would definitely
suggest you commission her for something
if you got something in mind as for the
next video well given what I mentioned
towards the beginning of this video
Blasphemous 2 is going to be up next As
for after I'm not too sure actually
there are quite a few new releases
coming out that I'm quite interested in
but if you want to know ahead of time
make sure to follow me on Twitter
regardless like the video if you enjoy
and subscribe if you're new thinking
about returning viewers coming back to
another video and take care everyone
goodbye